[Music]
megan's in topeka kansas hey megan
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey john how you guys doing
good what's up
um
i need to talk to you guys about a
stress that has been bothering me for
about five years um i adopted my
daughter
back in 2017 my oldest daughter and
her biological mom kept her
first social security card
and we got her social security number
changed
and we got her last name changed but
when we went to the social security
office they told us that there was no
guarantees
that her biological mother couldn't take
out a credit card or open up a loan on
that social security number
and
the lawyer that we had he did everything
he could to try and get it from her she
just wasn't surrendering i mean you
can't guarantee the bank isn't going to
get robbed by a crook
yeah and the mother the mother the birth
mothers obviously
you know got major issues going on she's
crooked potentially that's what's
scaring you how old's a kid right now
she's um gonna be eight next month good
well awesome that's great have you read
a credit report on her
i don't i well that was one of my
questions is i didn't know if i was
legally allowed to sure you're her
parent yeah you're a guardian absolutely
okay the other thing you can do that you
need to do is you need to freeze your
credit yeah freeze the other credit yeah
yeah i just need to know all the ways i
can protect her well number one you
can't yeah
completely
because there's skunks in the world and
it's the potential that her
birth mother's a skunk we don't know for
sure but there's a potential that's what
you're calling
but the things you can do is you can
check the check it make sure there's
nothing on it
the second thing you can do is freeze it
okay now if you freeze it what happens
is if someone checks her credit in order
to issue a
debt like a credit card for instance in
her name if they check her credit and
it's frozen they will not issue the debt
so birth mother uses uh old social
security number new social security
number new name old name whatever and
they check her credit and it's frozen
then
the credit card will be denied here's
the problem
only three in 10 credit cards do they
actually run a credit check on they just
automatically issue seven of them that's
how dead people and dogs get cards
you can get a dog issue in your poodle's
name
and i mean a card these they should
because these credit card companies are
stupid
they're just they're because in mass it
works out for them and they're just
running scale they're running large
numbers and so they might still
issue a card to the kid so what i would
do is i would go to zander insurance and
i would buy identity theft on the family
plan
and that includes coverage for your kids
it's not that expensive identity theft
insurance protection and what it'll do
then is if if someone
birth mother included
stole her identity and illegally opened
a card in her name
then they would assign a counselor to
that case and get it all removed and
cleaned up for you and that's why i
carry it on me my family
can i buy that um even
if she has coverage through my husband's
work
because i've been wanting to
she has coverage for what
through zander insurance
well through lifelock well lifelock does
not assign a counselor they do not
assign someone to take care of it for
you yes i'd pay the money yes i would
pay the money and go buy it from and go
buy it from xander because lifelock is
just a monitoring service
and take a breath you did something
noble and good
and it sounds like you're pre worrying
about things that might happen down the
road yeah
be present here be with your kid here
things are good things are good
enjoy the ride yeah man parenting's hard
enough as it is without imagining things
that could happen